we begin of course with the latest on
the corona virus and the awful awful
awful told from the corona viruses hit
yet another milestone and it's not good
us deaths have now surged to about
eleven thousand that's up from about
ninety six hundred yesterday morning the
u.s. now has more than three hundred and
sixty eight thousand reported cases and
Anthony the true number could be higher
because of under reporting that's right
Gil New York continues to have by far
the most cases in America but take a
look at this over the last twelve days
that states daily percentage increase in
cases has been trending downward and
that could mean the curve is starting to
flatten emphasize could a crew member
aboard the Comfort the Navy hospital
ship docked in New York City on the
Hudson River has tested positive for the
virus the Navy says the person is
isolated from patients and operations
will not be affected the diagnosis came
on the same day the ship was approved to
treat coronavirus patients following a
week-long delay Tony the US Surgeon
General dr. Jerome Adams joins us from
Washington he is a member of course of
the White House coronavirus Task Force
dr. Adams good morning good to see you
again
good morning good to be here I want to
begin I want to begin with those
glimmers of hope that the White House
has been pointing to in New York State
are hardest-hit state hospitalizations
and deaths have stabilized in the last
couple of days what does that tell us
about the fight here and the fight in
other emerging hotspots well absolutely
I started off the week telling Americans
that this was going to be a really rough
week but I also wanted Americans to
understand that when we've dealt with
tough times in the past the country has
rallied and and what we're seeing now is
the country is rallying we're seeing New
York and New Jersey have
hospitalizations level off and start to
come down deaths are starting to slow
down and level off and that's important
because it tells us mitigation is
working it tells us what the American
people are doing by staying at home by
social distancing by practicing good
hygiene and the 30-day guidelines for
America are actually effective and they
will help us get through to the other
side of this on
fortunate tragedy dr. Adams how can we
be sure that mitigation is working as
well as we hope it to be working when we
don't know to put it plainly how many
Americans actually have this virus
because we don't have widespread testing
so to put it more bluntly how do we know
when we're in the clear and we can get
back to normal if we don't know how
widespread this is well there are two
questions in there and I'll quickly
unpack both of them the most important
thing is that we know mitigation is
working because when we look at the
curves of Washington in California we
see that they've been very flat and
that's coincident with them instituting
aggressive mitigation we see Italy in
Spain down on the down slopes of their
curve coincident with them starting
mitigation so we know mitigation is
working now you mentioned testing
testing is a concern we are going to be
at 2 million tests this week and it's
rapidly ramping up with the commercial
industry coming on board we're also
seeing more people doing antibody
testing so what I want the American
people to know is I've talked with
Admiral Cho why I speak with him every
day he's our testing czar and he assures
me that by the end of this month we
should be not only just doing diagnostic
testing but also having good
surveillance testing across the country
at 2 million people by the end of this
week we're getting really close to South
Korea's initial testing surge numbers
and we are in fact doing surveillance
testing in some parts of the country
where they haven't seen a big increase
in cases so we're not there yet but we
are moving in the right direction and of
course that surveillance testing is so
important I want to touch on another
point of concern and that is the the
death rate among African Americans in
Louisiana we heard the governor say 70%
of the fatalities are people of color in
Chicago we heard the mayor say more than
70% in that city your response to that
and should the CDC or the federal
government be tracking this virus
demographically to warn people well
absolutely
the CDC and the federal government
should be and are tracking this virus
and trying to break it down by different
demographic groups so that we can help
people understand but my office long
before Kovan 19 has been talking about
health equity has been talking about the
need to help people understand when
they're at risk in to actually intervene
and when you look at
being black in America number one people
unfortunately are more likely to be of
low socioeconomic status which makes it
harder to social distance number two we
know that blacks are more likely to have
diabetes heart disease lung disease and
I've shared myself personally that I
have high blood pressure that I have
heart disease and spent a week in the
ICU due to a heart condition then I
actually have asthma and I'm
pre-diabetic and so I represent that
legacy of growing up poor and black in
America and I and many black Americans
are at higher risk for covin it's why we
need everyone to do their part to slow
the spread so doctor I imagine that it's
frustrating for you to hear those
numbers seventy percent of the dead in
Louisiana people of color African
Americans is there a particular
recommendation you have for that
community my recommendation my
recommendation is to understand that you
are at risk you are not immune and and
my recommendation is to all of America
that we're really doing this to protect
not just ourselves but each other every
single person who stays at home whether
you're white black brown or yellow is a
person who is not spreading kovat and as
a person who can protect their neighbors
when you wear a cloth facial covering if
you go outside you're doing it to
protect your neighbor now is really the
time for us to come together and say
look I'm doing this not just for me and
my family but I'm doing this for my
community and all the communities across
the country and it is working we will
get through this we are seeing progress
but America has the power to change the
trajectory of this epidemic the public
really needs to keep doing their part
all right dr. Jerome Adams thank you
very much for being here